Hey everyone, this is Mark Wiens with eating
Thai food dot com.
I'm at one of my favorite Thai street food
neighborhoods in Bangkok, Thailand, Ramkhamhaeng
Soi 29 and I'm heading to a tasty restaurant
just down the road, going to grab some Isaan
style Thai food.
One of the most important things about ordering
a Thai meal is to get a well rounded combination
of flavors and tastes.
So my meal has just arrived and I'm going
to show you guys exactly what I ordered and
how you can also order it that way.
This dish is called som tam thai prik ha met,
green papaya salad with five chillies.
It's crisp, it's a little bit sweet, a little
bit sour, it has a nice chili kick to it.
Another dish I ordered is a smoked catfish
salad known as larb pla duk, this is one of
my favorite dishes actually, I eat it almost
everyday.
And then I ordered up a pork dish known as
nam tok moo.
It normally comes with a lot of fat mixed
in, but I'm not big on the fat, so I ordered
it mai man, which means no fat, it's like
a grilled pork salad, it's fantastic.
Then I ordered something called yam ruam mit
talay, it's like a clear mung bean noodle
salad.
Lastly to round out this meal, I've ordered
tom saap sekong moo, a sour Isaan soup made
with pork ribs to make it extra flavorful.
Wonderful!
To accompany all of this food it's most typical
to order something known as khao neow, sticky
rice.
So you grab a piece of sticky rice and what
you want to do is flavor it with the different
sauces from the dishes, so I'll dip it in
the som tam first, it flavors it wonderfully.
If you love Thai food and you want to take
your eating to the next level, be sure to
grab a copy of the Eating Thai Food Guide,
it includes hundreds of different Thai dishes,
delicious Thai dishes, and it shows you instructions
on how to order them exactly how you want
them and even where to get them.
So be sure to click the link below, grab a
copy of the Eating Thai Food Guide and start
taking advantage of the awesome Thai food
available in Bangkok and throughout the country.
So all the remains of the feast are a few
fish bones, I'm stuffed and very happy.
OK, so that two hundred and forty baht for
this whole meal.
So anyway, grab a copy of the Eating Thai
Food Guide, I know you're going to love it,
it's full of all kinds of delicious Thai food
and you're going to learn how to order Thai
food exactly the way you want it.
That's it for me today, make sure you have
the best Thai food experience you can have!